the Joe Rogan experience so if I'm
Bernie Sanders why would I tell you how
much everything's gonna Trump the
personality overshadowed everything else
his personality overshadowed all of his
shortcomings so because of the fact that
he could say things like when he was
talking about China you know you could
go to China and you ever see that video
which one where he explains to China or
you could say listen [ __ ] have
you ever seen that video no pull that
video up cuz it's one of my favorite
Trump speeches it's like this is what
people love about dumb [ __ ] the fact
that he would say this think about who
Obama was right Obama this like
articulate statesman who you were proud
that that was the representative of
America he spoke so well he was so
measured so educated Donald Trump is not
that do you feel that some American
people since Obama was like that felt
like he was speaking down to them for
sure okay
dummies yeah don't be so like smart
people yeah that's always the case you
know but I don't think he was ever
speaking to people he's very measure I
don't I don't either but some people get
upset about that listen oh he doesn't
speak his mind he doesn't say what he
wants to say people don't like him
because he's a liberal that some people
don't like because he's black to some
people that don't like him because he's
young some people don't like him because
he went to Harvard here it is listen to
this so listen I play this because it's
one of my favorite Trump speeches ever I
drop a 25% tax on shine
and you know I said to somebody that is
really the messenger the messenger is
important I could have one man say way
to tax you 25% and I could say another
listen you [ __ ]
he does not give a [ __ ]
he doesn't anything people keep saying
he's dumb he's not dumb he's just not
concentrating on the things that
intelligent people concentrate on way
it's concentrating on money money
he's constitutes as ego himself he's not
concentrating on I mean when he's talk
he's not talking about the Glick the
great literary works he's talking about
not talking about great philosophers or
great historians these are not things as
he's concentrating on his whole life he
has a sharp mind but his whole life he's
been concentrating on Donald Trump and
Donald Trump kicking ass and Donald
Trump's name and Donald Trump's ego and
filling that ego and cheating at golf
and doing all the things that he wants
to do whenever he wants to do that's
what he concentrated on it doesn't mean
that he's dumb and that's what people
get distracted that they get confused I
agree with you on that but but what I'm
surprised about look and I don't care
what side offense yeah but what I'm
surprised about is some people believe
he's doing things for the country's best
interests not for his own well he's
definitely doing things for his best
interests 100 percent and also probably
doing things that he thinks are for the
country's best interest as well I don't
think all of what he's doing is just for
him because you wouldn't be President if
you did that that doesn't make any sense
because it the the beating that you take
in terms of like well it's also your ego
boost by but he's also getting rid of
everyone that opposes him or so I mean
well that's how he runs all of his
companies exactly so that's how you
would run a company and you kept the guy
70 [ __ ] three years old right when
you're that old you don't change you
know you know I mean the way he runs
companies to expect him to do any
different once he became president it's
kind of silly that's how he's become
successful I mean that's why his [ __ ]
name is on these giant buildings all
over the world right it's like it's this
ego thing and the way he does business
I'm the [ __ ] boss
listen you [ __ ] we're gonna tax
you 25% that's his attitude that's his
thought
[Applause]